Austin River we're opening our own club
the fathership
actually we're gonna need to please
allow for this if you can swim don't
apply I'll help you I'll be your rat
yeah I'll be your life
hey wait man
bro
how come you stopped on the rift bro
yeah okay Brendan somebody needs to get
you no yeah no no no
no ah
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
do nothing I really didn't no Brian and
I are really close well terrify is much
younger than me so I always just figured
he was like uh
yeah yeah like a comic you know a comic
kid I was older than everybody right not
not physically as we know it not
physically I'll I'll give you a run for
your money yeah so physically yeah but
physically you throw me in a in an arena
full of 30 year old comedians put your
money on me right put your money on me
absolutely right
hold on first one to die what did you
say take it back for real
take it back you think you'd beat up any
comedian under 30.
it's I I'm gonna be in the index with
any comedian no yeah you'll give it your
best to go I'm
fine don't and I [__] say that and
after when you're dying I'll go do you
have fun okay listen
I'm good for the first day the problem
is I I recovery is a problem because
I've seen Jeremiah mess some people like
slapped the piss out of people you see
what yeah Jeremiah if you want to go
what yeah he's a dad now yeah so I've
got more on the line I've got a family
to defend now you take you take a flat
handle a man oh yeah really so
disrespectful or a disrespectful woman
yeah dude yeah uh I've got more of an
edge since we last hung out yeah
I didn't even know you were married with
Children so you're your wife yeah you
and I have stayed in touch it's been
good yeah he comes and Rangers yeah kids
yeah yeah he can play he can play a mean
sax oh I know that we all know so you
got you got crazy yeah
you got parody you got soul and you'll
take a flat hand to a man
she's disrespectful you shouldn't do
this dude you are different no I've
changed I've changed a lot since you
last saw me you've changed a lot dude
yeah your hair's shorter yeah there's no
you don't even blink I'm done being a
nerd man
I'm done with it I decided we have a
hundred pound kettlebell out there and
Jeremiah goes should I bring the
Kettlebell into the showroom yeah no no
no no it's okay different guy man
different the only thing is maybe a
little trt
um
how old are you now what you how old are
you does it matter no it doesn't it
doesn't you probably I like this you
probably 22 23 years old yeah you got a
lot of stuff going on yeah this is what
happens when you become a dad oh dude
it's different now just that Dad was
different you got straight teeth and a
crooked smile too oh good and one of the
few guys that can pull off and you're
white and Asian at the same time you
don't know that yeah it's cool I have an
Asian cup because on my podcast Brendan
has an Asian Coast on his pocket of
school I've never heard this before hey
I'm Brian Cowan I'm really tired and
sleepy all the time and what's going on
that's a stereotypical
that's a super stereotypical impression
of me oh you have a nice mustache yes I
understand Kung Fu yes are you Chinese
I immerse myself I can't tell the
difference between you and Chin
sometimes Fair Point holy [__] this has
been a few more wrinkles yeah man you
know what you were worried when all that
Asian hate was going on you didn't show
up to the studio but I'm like what is
going on bro yeah I saw some headlines
I'm like oh no Brian got hit again yeah
yeah yeah they're really taking it too
many streets
like oh that's my buddy I feel bad guys
I'm like he had a comments yeah guys you
see you see a man step to me on the
street you will see another man named
Brian count dig his heels into the
American
you guys see a man
you see somebody step to Brian Callan
are you are you telling him right now
what's up you will see Brian Callan dig
his heels into the American soil and
answer back with a ferocity unlike
you've seen and you dealt with but you
didn't give a you're a good old
kids say the good old College you're
making me super mad because I I I stay
in Crazy shape and I don't like how
you're talking man you're disrespectful
ah man dude that hand is really close to
Brendan's face I don't appreciate it
[__] man I I you don't make me slap the
dude oh dude I I will fight you in front
of Jeremiah and I will slap you gladly
watching space
your enemy your enemy Jeremiah what have
you been up to you got a special out
subject change yeah yeah it's subject
change yeah I got a special out okay
what's it called it's called daddy read
the shirt
I actually love that merch I I will I
will wear that did you did you shoot it
at The Comedy Store uh oh gotcha all
right
such a good room Beastie yeah why there
is that where you're from
no uh I just love the club I decided to
shoot it there all right where do you
hail from where the hell from Kansas
Kansas couldn't be more Kansas really
well you got the where are you from you
got the coloring where am I from bro
lots of different places oh really at
the end of the day the street and I'm
from right [__] here okay right here
right here right now I'm from right here
right [__] okay yeah
technically you'd say you're from New
York but you know my roots well my
Italian Roots right so so my mom my mom
bought a race in Brooklyn I'm friends
with 50 Cent yeah yeah the other one
time I was about 10 years ago I never
been more embarrassed 10 years ago I
went I said uh yeah well that well
that's the difference between me I'm
Sicilian I would and I and I was about
to go into how what I would do to this
person because they got me riled up yeah
and my buddy Hunter Mott's tailpiece
goes yeah where Brian isn't from he
doesn't take that [__] at all he'll tell
you he's from Brooklyn never lived there
he'll tell you Sicilian grew up overseas
at the end of the day he's not from
anywhere but he wishes he was story yeah
you gotta because you want to put your
roots down somewhere but you grew up
overseas nobody wants to claim him man I
I was really I started I was trying to
write Scripts and a guy who taught
writing and was a really good very
successful Hollywood writer he said you
know what your problem is you're not
from anywhere and you don't have any and
he goes there's no place where you write
from there's you don't have plans you
know your problem is you're from nowhere
right so you represent nobody and also a
white male yeah isn't that weird kind of
screwed yeah yeah so I never had
anywhere the only place I would identify
with the longest I lived was New York
City you know New York does I guess you
claim New York you go to New York with
Brian it's real proper yeah oh yeah yeah
he knows all the spots man because I got
folded into real a group of real New
Yorkers two comedy into in Jimmy Brooks
Mr New York but if you if you and you
I'm sure you perform New York yeah if
you go there and don't know anybody it's
it kind of sucks yeah it's a it's a
nightmare it's a harmful City yeah if
you're if you're in lonely if you don't
have a friend group out there yeah if
you don't know like where to go and like
yeah navigate it's a lot I take your
watch on your wallet yeah right you
don't have a watch
yeah reach behind me here I hate that
dump trick behind the ear people reach
behind my nose
talking about he went to David Blaine's
uh Magic Show in Las Vegas and uh like
the way he tells it is a raven
came flying out of nowhere and landed on
him on Danny and Danny DeVito's like had
a note in its beak or something like
it's not magic but keep going well it's
kind of weird that they're just trying
to [__] bird they're smart as [__] no
it was something I can't remember how he
describes it out of all the [__] David
Blaine does David Dave Lane's watching
he's like bro
David Blaine brought a dog out he made a
Sit no I know what happened he turned
Danny he turned into into a black girl
no but did you see David Blaine actually
got hurt he was doing a stunts and he
like oh here it is here how'd he do that
he takes a hundred dollar bill the
Crow's mouth
was all folded up 100 hour bill that
matched the serial number corner of our
that we had that he burned up that's
crazy any questions come on that's great
any questions that's good you don't
think that's a big deal you know your
story is better right believable I mean
so wait give me your dollar bill serial
number out of all the shades David
Blaine is done hold on give me a dollar
bill
yeah pull up the DeVito
out of all the things
yeah I know that's
that's out of all the [__] Dave Wayne's
done when he did Magic for you at my
house insane insane insane yeah better
than that story yeah well he'll he'll
kill you every time you had him over as
a house
I'm going to a show in Vegas we should
go I'm gonna take my kid we should take
we should take our kids all right yes
seven he'd be terrified like stabs
through his [__] arms
big by the way that big dude like you
show that like you posted a video to
your Instagram recently like he was
filling up the back seat I was like dude
he's bigger than Brian all right that's
140. yeah well he's got what gets me is
his trap he's on keto though we gotta
you gotta slim him down
man he's got he's on straight up where'd
it go grin
uh probably that video he's in the back
yeah it's watch the size of him the
reveal of like
yeah I was like
are those kids his age yeah what one's
his brother right yeah the other kids
yeah seven dude go back to that again go
back dude it's great he's like a DD he's
like ready to hop in at any moment he's
gonna play football he's enormous he's
so big no we got my strict diet though
he's getting out when you see him
standing there like you sent me that
picture of him his his neck and traps
he's got a neck and traps already
someone said when did Tiger turn 27.
dude that's it oh my God that's insanity
that is easy he's giantism
yeah the kid that's one of his best
friends on the right dude he's so big
that's one of the coolest that's on the
sidelines of a football game yeah yeah
let's take a little break from chat with
our boy Jeremiah Watkins whose special
just dropped on YouTube called Daddy
because listen you and I are busy and we
hate going to the doctor man it takes
half your day to get things done you
also you don't want to talk to your
doctor about certain issues if you have
some weird things going on here's the
thing most men's health issues have
really Simple Solutions very simple
solution Rex MD is here and they're all
about Simple Solutions Rex MD makes
getting generic and branded Viagra or
Cialis easy everything's online even the
prescription and they deliver right to
your door no office visits no talking to
a receptionist very simple dude did you
know Viagra can cost around 90 bucks a
pill but Rex MD has a generic Viagra for
as low as two dollars the exact same
thing when you say generic it's exactly
what you see in the biography all you
gotta do is fill out a quick medical
questionnaire on their website a doctor
will review your situation and prescribe
you genetic value if appropriate your
medication gets shipped right to your
door with free two-day shipping it's
fast simple and cheap you can access
your us license RX MD physician anytime
you need 300 000 guys get generic Viagra
quickly and conveniently Arena problems
out there this is correct act now take
advantage of their deal by heading to r
r e x MD rexmd.com spider our exclusive
deal will save up to 90 off where you'll
pay as low as two dollars per dose on
generic Viagra instead of 90 Plus on
Viagra starter packs of generic Viagra
or Cialis are now available for our
listeners to get started that's
rexmd.com spider for up to 90 off and a
free gift a free gift your wiener will
thank you yeah and your partner so your
partner
the best nuts on the planet macadamia
nuts dude you know I you know I'm a Nut
they call me the nut man call me nut
file is that why your skin looks so
silky if you want to get rid of nuts I'm
your guy this is you yeah put in my
mouth yeah well put them on Damien not
set you back here's the thing dude this
mouth I got quite the palate yeah it
only likes expensive rare Macadamia if
you're if you're not a millionaire you
don't get macadamia nuts because they're
that expensive I'm going broke paying
for Macadamia House of macadamia what
now these 90 Farmers from South Africa
House of macadamia works with 90 Farmers
they will bring you the best macadamia
nuts on the planet but is it just like
raw nuts with salt chocolate dipped oh I
love white chocolate dipped what about
bars they got bars they got white
chocolate bars they got the best I'm
telling you this stuff is so delicious
it's ridiculous it's got the best fat
profile a better fat profile and they
have omega-7 seven fatty acids B if you
tell me if I order you can give me a
discount and then give me a free bottle
of cold press extra virgin Macadamia Oil
I'm gonna bust with nuts oh wait you
mean the the macadamia oil that the
Nokes Foundation recently did a study of
where they found that it outperformed
coconut oil and olive oil and its
beneficial effects on overall human
health you mean that stuff yeah dude
give them 20 off their order for a
limited time with also a free bottle of
cold pressed extra virgin Max oil
discounts okay but if you did but you
know what if I did and I'm going to all
right house of macadamias special offer
use code tfak
for 20 off your order and for a limited
time yep we are gifting listeners a free
bottle oh my God I said it of cold
pressed extra virgin Macadamia Oil put
it all over your body put it all over
your body put in your hair pan put it
don't get in your eyes though tell you
from your boy don't put in your eyes on
the floor you're gonna sleep not for
your eyes grease your eyes Daddy got in
his eyes my mouth was full of nuts okay
I couldn't see but I was still happy got
a little crazy now I will say this house
of macadamus.com
t-f-a-k 20 off is this Fair though since
since we've become they become a sponsor
we've eaten macadamia nuts every day
would you say full of nuts every day
they're so good it's stupid I'm full of
nuts my whole family's eating them we
got them just live give you a smile on
my face full of nuts full of positive
attitude positive attitude nutty naughty
House of macadamus.com
tfak no
that's right not tfak sorry
tfak dude how's the macadamias.com tfak
yeah man and that kid's crazy soccer
players in the business establishment
that's another kid but that kid that I
talked to that Dad this morning the
other night I'm gonna say his name but
the other night he uh just went blind in
his left eye he's like and start
throwing up he's like this ain't normal
it goes the emergency room it's like two
nights ago
tumor tumor on the in his brain they do
emergency surgery yeah crazy is it a bad
tumor uh wasn't cancerous it wasn't no
thank God I know man because that's
that's yeah yeah this got dark fast no
but at least it wasn't canceled oh thank
God my friend had the same thing yeah
same exact thing happened to him and
they were like you know and then he it
was like not cancerous zero to a hundred
he was like I was chilling and then
David Blaine made it disappear my Crow
came and took the tooth he took the door
took the tumor gave him a hundred dollar
bill yeah
um have you been any desire to go to
Austin like the rest of the LA Comics I
visited a couple times I was just out
there for uh for moon tower and um
that's like one of my favorite festivals
uh out there and then uh we did a kill
Tony uh we did like a band reunion like
a few weeks before school yeah yeah so
that was fun any desire to move out
there no yeah it's tough yeah I love
visiting I I love the scene there it's
cool like like I got up yeah there's a
bunch of places to get it it feels so
concentrated like it's a real orgy yeah
Yeah but I living there I I wouldn't
want to couldn't do it yeah life is not
down
I'm not down you don't want to do it I
wouldn't want to you don't want access
to your own well and gain meat in the
freezer you don't want to grow an
aggressive beard and take a lot of
Jiu-Jitsu and carry guns no no no I'm
good at the moment I I grew up with guns
though in Kansas yeah yeah I was an NRA
member at like six
yeah man dude that's what you have to do
he has a dead eye yeah you look like you
could you could pick me off at a mile
away oh yeah yeah with a win win mag
wait you have two kiddos now uh second
one is coming in June uh boy or girl do
you know another boy oh two boys yeah
two boys two boys yeah Dad life's
different right it is yeah yeah but good
it's like a it's like a remix on life
yeah it just gives you perspective for
sure yeah I love it I do too you know
can you imagine browsing yeah it's not
really for me yeah
yeah besides Herschel Walker I think
it's not really for me yeah yeah kids I
think those dads leave I think yeah
anytime I hear a dad go man I love my
human I [__] hope so yeah yeah yeah I
don't need you to tell me that but there
are there's a pretty high profile I
don't know you know anyone that told me
that if they said ah it's just not for
me I'm like see ya you get out of here
yeah what are you doing but there are
people who um like like we know like
like probably Herschel Walker and stuff
you see these people you got to be It's
Tricky though right if somebody's older
and they don't talk to their dad and
they go bad sometimes you might have a
kid it's just maybe
I don't know you know like Carl Malone
had that kid with that age girl when he
was like he was like super young so it's
you know he was like I don't know 18 or
something like that she was like 14. and
then he was just getting going so maybe
he didn't have the mental capacity deal
with being a dad I don't know it's like
you never know what's going on there but
some guys when the kid comes to Isaac my
dad was never around like bro he was 17.
yeah yeah although some people I've been
to that at 17. I can't imagine that at
all do you ever like 16 and Pregnant I'd
watch that and not have kids I'm like
how the F how the [__] did these kids
figure it out right and they don't it's
a nightmare It's usually the the mom
like their mom of this oh yeah they have
to raise yeah the grandparents are
raised that's basically all it is yeah
so y'all are having the kids like no
your mom's the one who the
fatherlessness is like you can trace
that back to almost all anti-social
Behavior with boys suicide anti-social
Behavior a thousand things so with a boy
grown up without a father is not a good
idea oh even now with the uh you know my
son he's in a million Sports I hang out
with other parents if the dad's not in
their life like or the nanny's raising
the kids you can the kids attitude is
completely different because they have
good parents yeah the lashing out in
some way yeah they just don't know they
don't know where the line is there's no
doubts now that's 100 how do you
discipline your kids because that's a
hard-handed
it's a hard hand to the face it needs to
learn yeah I wet a rod I dip a rod in
oil hmm yeah uh yeah I don't believe in
hitting your your kid yeah I mean I
don't think you can these days I don't
think you can I don't think anybody is
coming out now like in public again just
call the cops or go on Reddit you know
and that'll screw me up you're like I
already have enough trolls on right I
don't need my kids on there too Tiger's
like my dad
hey man
the real Gringo poppy Oh serious yeah
there he is I've never really um
understood the logic I got hit and you
know a lot of people in my generation
where it's like everyone did something
riding crop to my legs yeah belts spoons
yeah but science but now with science
and more technology I realize that the
kids don't learn that way oh it does
terrified of the parents well it just
humiliates them I just don't I've never
said to myself oh he's not listening I'm
gonna hit him like I'll grab my son and
go hey look at me you know if he's being
disrespectful but to actually strike a
child I've never had that uh I just
so it's like that's tough you don't
understand but with tiger at seven well
if he's doing something or you know if
he had bad grade something I take stuff
away from so I take like certain things
away and then he's like damn dude yeah
like you want it back you see real quick
yeah yeah my son's two so I mean that's
different yeah it's there's no rationale
like with their like with their minds at
the level he's at so you know you really
like if he's crying or something like
that or he like has a tantrum like it's
usually because he's hungry or tired or
something yeah usually tired I don't
know how to put it into context no yeah
he literally like I had just gotten home
off the road and like he got upset about
something he's like no Dada like he
didn't want to look at me and then like
three seconds later he's like Dada yeah
yeah you know yeah well that way to
realize you're leaving that's dude he's
starting to pick up that I'm leaving
three they start getting literally last
night he goes no work Dada I was like oh
man this is crushing me yep you didn't
say I ain't a millionaire you go work
that yeah yeah yeah
you want to pick up some of the slack
around here yeah I I the one thing I'm
behind on rent for two years a little
bit it used to be dads would be like
when I was your age you have no idea how
how easy you have it I don't like doing
that to a kid either no that kind of
that kind of yeah it's like dude you're
the adult of course of course I'm gonna
have it easier than you he's like yeah I
wasn't living in the 50s I have no
[__] clue what you went through right
it's their perspective right and also I
have to deal with social media okay yeah
yeah
yeah but who hits their kids I don't I
mean
a lot of culture still oh like you know
you take your sandal off and give them a
whacking you know it's like there are
certain things that people do yeah
you're wearing sandals today uh these
are flip-flops these are Toe Hold flips
they're 800 so 400 no 450 bucks these
are the eyes
the samurai well they're the best
flip-flops on the planet and you'll
never need another pair ever ever dude
they're yeah and they mold to your feet
and this is saying something is the best
flip-flop 500 steps handmade
[__] yeah it's like saying I
want a gold at Special Olympics yeah no
it's not these are the best flip-flops
on the planet I take it easy I used to
be I used to own the company but I I
don't anymore or a part of the company
but you're pitching is like we want to
buy something it's still a great company
best best flip-flops everybody yeah
are you gonna cry
[Music]
flip-flops thank you wait while they're
crushing our sandals like a slur to the
flip-flop Community uh yes is that uh
that's like but the company's killing it
right now bring up their uh no maybe
let's not do this hey please listen no
bring up their rash guard bring up their
rash guard why are we doing promos for
them we're not doing promos for let me
think that the whole that's a minute
promo so what it's a great company but I
just want to show you neither one of us
already I want to show you I want to
show you this [__] uh we know you do
a lot of jokes will you pull up that
damn DeVito clip again look what they're
selling out in this is so crazy you know
rash people Pete rash guard
that's kind of crazy that's what they're
selling out I wear a rash guard for
Boogie boarding and that's it yeah so
keyboard yeah dude is that a problem
uh no where do you pick keyboard's fun
it's fun if you can't surf yeah surf you
gotta go a lot but also it's such an
ordeal to like if you know to hook into
a car or something like that like a
surfboard and all that stuff so I don't
know I like the boogie board it's fun
that was very judgmental I wanted it was
very judgmental you went
fully guy pushing I've always wanted
to draw the line yeah that's boogie
board well I'd like to uh I'd like to be
a surfer but that's not going to happen
I went so good I went you just have to
do it a lot here's the problem it takes
a while say golf you don't try it out no
you got to do it all the [__] day too
much of a commitment
I've been playing a hot second you there
was like a pitch and Putt uh course that
we did a moon tower where it was like
comedians miked up so it was like me
Adam Ray Brad Williams like oh that's my
mics and that was fun those boys in
Austin golf all the time like Jamie the
producer for Rogan Tony oh golfs all the
time all the time all the time yeah
Casey here golf solving Casey's like
really [__] really yeah it's never
the only time I was with my dad but I
just I find it a very I just don't have
six hours to go it's a lot to it's a lot
to kill time yeah it's a huge computer
you never surfed me why I surfed yeah
one first statement always almost every
day yeah I'm on board two boards I loved
it loved it but then if you don't go
enough then you're just falling down
yeah
the other thing is when you have kids
you can't be like I'm going surfing I'll
see you later unless you wake up super
early in the morning or something but
when I wake up early enough but it's
just such a commitment I mean I do I
love surfing I remember uh when the UFC
countdown I forget who I was fighting
but they're like oh you surf right I'm
like yeah because I just moved to LA
like are we gonna film yeah wasn't very
good and they were filming like
literally for an hour and like are you
so are you gonna like surf or you just
kind of get up there and fall yeah yeah
and just like speed it up yeah literally
a complete waste of time all they just
show me walk into the ocean with my
board
please show some other guys right well a
lot of it's just catching the wave like
that there's a lot you know when I
stopped I was like I I went out with the
European freestyle Champion uh my buddy
Joey paid for the guy so he would catch
the wave for me and all I do is just
jump on the wave and just stare at the
shore and I'm surfing I tried doing on
my own impossible it's getting up it's
the whole it's like you really gotta
learn how to get it so then I go out
with a guy in Venice I go I'm gonna
learn how to surf
I go out and the guy goes the guy goes
so what I would recommend is that you
just you got to get wave knowledge you
don't have any wave knowledge right now
so you just got to spend a lot of time
in the water and I was like I don't I'm
out too old now I don't care anymore I
was also so big my board was like
[__] nine foot long and people like
oh paddle boarding like no yeah yeah my
boy is giant not very cool no I got um
when I was Boogie boarding one time I
got stung by a stingray oh on the foot
no huh you gotta shuffle your feet
I know that now okay bro I'm just saying
you're telling me years after it
happened if I could have used you yeah
no I literally I hopped off a wave and
it was it was waiting yeah there's
nothing yeah awful yeah they say it's 50
times more potent than a bee sting oh
yeah
dude it was up there for sure I was
gushing blood and then the Panic sets in
because like I took it out of the water
and then it's like and then I'm like oh
the shark should smell blood from you
was the Barb in your foot no luckily
like it had pulled out but what happens
is it's really serrated where it goes in
and then it pulls out so on the outside
that's what they said kill the crocodile
hunter if you would have left it in they
could have had surgery survived yeah but
when it goes into the barbs yeah and
they yanked it out
yep and the only way to do it uh on a
foot because to extract the poison is
you they dunk your water you dunk your
foot over and over and nearly boiling
water so like to suck it sucks the
poison out so you have to so part of the
pain is the actual poison that's
coursing through your blood but part of
it is you're like killing your foot in
the hot water and also when you're on
the ocean okay somebody get me a bucket
of boiling water oh I would do lifeguard
saying if you're out in the middle of
nowhere like you're screwed yeah Jesus
yeah so that that's why Rockfish like in
Japan Okinawan stuff when people go
wherever those that's where you're from
where yes it is it's where I study
karate oh it's that it's where I became
kind of day in a way but um you wear
felt you wear felt booties but a lot of
people who don't know don't wear foul
boot booties and my buddy saw a guy step
on a rockfish went in a cardiac arrest
right there bring up that Rockfish chin
whoa they're brutal looking died it's
called something else all right no it's
called a rockfish Rockfish is what we
eat
stonefish
super dangerous
now would you ever have one of those I'm
surprised you don't have one of those in
your town I don't have a saltwater tank
yet but you will though right still with
fresh imagine if you had that bad boy
that'd be cool but also my kids would be
like oh that's just a rough so oh so the
horn got them uh if you step on any of
those oh it just looks like a rock yeah
that's the most poisonous one right
there
um this one
no
is that business still
I don't think so dude I think it kind of
hit its Heyday like you know Aubry
Marcus that was his thing well I think
that uh now they have these high-tech if
you're really into that they have
high-tech [__] dolls that dude the level
that of
jacking off you have to be at to order a
sex doll and then and then you know you
have to hide it from your bodies and
hopefully it shows up worse hopefully it
shows up with discreet packaging I would
imagine like over the box and say like
[__] no but I think they're like six
double D yeah you're okay I think
there's six thousand dollars or
something crazy oh those are real dolls
you're getting your money's worth yeah
right just but think you just feel kind
of weird like oh I'm gonna jack off let
me go get the sex no it's like 120
pounds yeah drag it out of the closet
yeah like Loop it up yeah it's like
bearing then you gotta clean then you
gotta clean it out oh she looks natural
it does look natural
it's really interesting it's just a
weird thing like I don't you know hate
on any way that does that it's just the
whole setup dude I mean I mean like
where do you put in your house I don't
know we should probably buy one entry
level I mean I wonder if it comes with
like a hanger where you put it up okay
entry-level sex doll I'm talking about
the mid-rangement not with the real deal
yeah let me get the best one dude high
end yeah of course let me see the what's
the ten thousand dollar one get this way
you should know a few uh highest quality
tpe in Silicon
all sizes weights are possible ooh can I
get a thick one yeah the body
they're all dude out of all the dolls
you chose them it's ages it ages well
three plus years very durable and sturdy
due to strong skeletons three orifices
wow highly customizable that one on the
left I'd like what the hell yeah I don't
know what's going on with some of these
Asian the bottom left looks like she has
an attitude I don't think that's high
yeah it looks like it says
looks like a signal is gonna judge you
[__] yeah disgusting yeah yeah
interesting yeah it's going down a weird
Road man you got to be a real different
type of dude the blow up one it's just
like what what are you doing man if you
get a blow up a waste of [__] I mean
that's straight like back to the 80s
I mean you're just wasting that's sexy
you'll be a real creep to get that
blower
just like that dude oh dude how about
this [__] hands oh man oh hands and
feet oh well how about my boy Jimmy oh
you're a serial killer Bubba how about
my boy Jimmy Burke biking in New York
sees a glove on the ground and just goes
what the [__] is that picks it up
there's a hand in it
yeah the real hand a separate hand in
the glove you know some cool people man
smiley faces I got great stories who
knows what most of them are even true
but it doesn't matter this is a podcast
right I said Jimmy what'd you do with
the hand he goes I just threw it down I
go did you call it I wouldn't touch it
because no I just wrote away who's just
this word gets weird I mean your boy uh
uh Stevie weeby had the butt I don't
know the upper right hand corner oh
that's so weird that serial killer
that's right you were responsible to
dispose of that that's in the freaking
storage room hold on show me oh show me
that thumb again whoa that's the most
incredible thumb I've ever do I wanna I
want a [__] t-shirt at that did you
break it no my thumbs are just like that
oh my God Ryan wants to make a mold of
your hands and jack up I don't know what
you're talking about I just wanna
t-shirt yeah because Stevie weeby had
the chocolate out yeah yeah and then he
was ashamed of it and he brought it here
to set it on five right
yeah please brother he had a Stevie Lee
Bobby has a brother yeah Jesus Christ
yeah he's on King The Sting for a hot
stuff yeah wrestled him yeah
Bobby has a brother yeah [__] man and I
have this baby
where were you Brian where were you
sorry buddy yes tbyu is all about that
chocolate ass he always used to hate
when he used to bring it up I used to
love it I used to love it there's some
great stories chocolate ass that he
bought yeah on put so you tell us about
like the stuff yeah yeah and he was like
ashamed of it oh wow and then he got rid
of it brought it this dude and set it on
fire I mean it's good he got he has a
girlfriend now so it's it's good that it
worked out it worked out that you guys
took care I'm sure his kids will never
look this up my dad the problem is that
when we've done as much podcasting as we
have we say everything yeah so my kids
are going to have an archive of who
their dad over here in college we were
able to listen to whatever 10 000
episodes is just my [__] the good
news is there's too much to go through
it's just like I don't think so no
they're committed yeah
he's so funny I'll bring him up I think
David Cho bought him the thing as a gift
that's what Stevie said at least oh
that's where it originated it is
something somebody has to buy you yeah
if you bought me a ten thousand dollar
sex doll I'm not gonna throw it away
yeah just out of you know respect oh
yeah right yeah I just don't know I'd be
like what do you want me to do with this
thing dude
oh boy that hairline why are we showing
this oh this is Stevie B yeah that's my
scissor Brother Stevie weeby how scissor
Bros going you guys still doing well
good yeah doing our thing man
yep yep hey Stevie we gotten up anymore
stand up wise he was getting up for a
little he did another uh we're gonna
release it like uh probably uh like in a
month or so he did another episode of
stand up on the spot and he killed like
he's one of those guys where if he put
effort into doing stand up
he would so easily he's so naturally
funny yeah I give him uh like 10 minutes
when I was uh where was that right yeah
yeah so funny yeah he came off he was
like so worried I'm like not for your
like third time doing it man that's
[__] dude yeah he's great that's a
pretty amazing comedic gene pool yeah I
don't know I didn't know he had a
brother but I'm sure yeah I know
Stevie's great yeah he's funny in a very
different way than Bob completely
different Bobby did Bobby was doing his
thing and and it was like Bobby was
talking about how he needs to write more
or something and uh he's writing a lot
now I think but but I don't know but um
Eric Griffin said the best thing about
Bobby he said Bobby could do that for
the rest of his life and it's like a Led
Zeppelin song like it's just always good
no matter what it's just his no he has
an ability I've never seen it with any
other comic where it sounds fresh every
single time he delivered it yeah
unbelievable yeah
well we need to get Stevie weeby another
chocolate ass is what what a conclusion
that's the conclusion that's where we've
come hey is there any sandal flashlights
online
now listen dude because the way you talk
about your shoes if you want it
yeah well the Leathers would feel good
on your dong oh it's weird
I imagine you you know there's like the
the bottle openers on the bottom
sometimes I imagine you'd be like no no
no not with my bespoke these are my new
ones so I'm kind of attached to them I
like that they the black dude just I
mean just that you have your feet out
and open in public
you can go on a plane right and I won't
I won't disgusting I don't wear them
nothing worse what you're doing is the
ultimate white people sport no I like I
like my toes to be flailed now don't
wear them hiking because you get stung
by a bee when you step on a whole bee's
nest and then that happened to me it's
not even the B but why would you hike in
this I they they hey hey hey
fabric sauce not for hiking though uh
absolutely not that's how the company
was started that's so stupid I choose
dude when you're hiking I like my feet
I'm not sure I'll bro do you still bike
a lot Brendan oh yeah yeah all the time
yeah all the time once a week three
times a week really yeah we didn't have
this at 10 30.
no it's been hot and I thought I'd see
more I haven't seen them since the
pandemic a lot of them oh dude yeah all
the time I never see them well now but
now so many people up they scare them
away like during the pandemic when
nobody was up there I'd see how they
came out of the way it was the best now
I rarely ever you get bit by one of
those bad boys think about that uh-huh
you know what I mean it's a rattlesnake
yeah
you'll be a real [__] unless you just
walking in the um they're not aggressive
no they're doing their thing they're
dope my dad uh stomped a rattlesnake out
with cowboy boots to death so gangster
yep yeah because like it was it was near
us [__] oh dude it was near us like at
like our family our family van
it was epic oh yeah oh dude
yeah it was incredible well when I lived
in India and Pakistan
was up there oh cobras probably and that
was a real presence and a real problem
that was a real issue and some people
would keep uh like dogs German Shepherds
and stuff because they could cause a
problem for the they at least distract
the [__] things yeah chin bring up
how many people die from cobras in India
the numbers alarming oh it's alarming
also you know you know that number you
know that number's hacked right you know
so you know uh what they found out so
they had this crazy number of people
being killed by cobras right so they
were like what's going on what they
found out
was that um when a husband would brain
his wife when he'd kill his wife in a
domestic dispute he'd be like she got
bit by a snake and they'd bury her in a
hurry and or or burn the corpse actually
and uh and that was that was well you
believe that and you don't believe JFK
was a hoax huh look at that
130. hey what uh go to how many people
die annually from cobras
that's a lot
12 percent
kill about 15 000 people across several
countries that's a lot of people yeah
that's a lot I mean that's a problem
it's a problem so you know so how about
this
how about this is the best when the
British come to India they start getting
bit some of the Lords get bit their kids
are getting bit by cobras right saying
we can't have this [__] so they
basically issue an edict the entire
Indian population and they go we will
give you the equivalent of whatever a
dollar a snake so we want you to kill
every Cobra you can find so all the
Indians go out and start killing cobras
and they bring them to the magistrate
store and he would Dole out money
literally the British Empire had a
policy of paying people to kill cobras
they're like we got a billion people
here we can kill all the cobras here's
what they didn't take into account
got a couple entrepreneurs who go cobras
I can make money off of cobras I'll just
start breeding cobras and they had a
whole tradition of snake Charmers there
so all of a sudden they got [__] pits
of cobras being bred in every poor
neighborhood and that just created a
major culture is like you owe me thirty
thousand dollars right and that killed
50 000 and that's what they're doing and
then they figure they get they get wise
to it they say [__] all this then they
let all the cobras out they're like all
right just let them out now you got a
real problem India's a problem because
you got cobras you also got Tigers out
there oh yeah let me oh yeah tigers are
real crocodiles Crocs and other
poisonous snakes in India and then not
dementia
and it's Untouchables
let's not forget there was they've got
they've made incredible scribes but but
now cuddles right they need all the
strides they made incredible scribes but
they had a real poverty and problem yeah
that's something God damn you got
leopards what else a lot of it leopards
elephantes whatever [__] out of my face
yeah
they killed it they got sideburns
I'm not worried about it I'm begging you
holy [__] a Bengal tiger that's a
terrible problem terrifying oh we're
fine sloth bears kill a lot of people
common crite most poisonous snake in the
world most poisonous snake in the world
right there you get bit with that you're
done saltwater crocodile that's India is
worse than Australia oh yeah dude don't
kid yourself rock python nothing get out
of them stupid [__] off stupid no it's
not fun step on it problem
king cobra you're the big hood and
cobras you [__] soft-scaled Viper
somebody died very poisonous problem
mosquito malaria we forgot about malaria
yeah that comes back to Poverty yes keep
going
out of all the deadly animals that we're
seeing it's a white person it's like a
laugh hey let me get this
get this stray dog over the Bengal tiger
yeah okay yeah and also this dog isn't
even biting that person's hand or
anything and that dog [__] too yeah you
know when they use the wrong guy for
they carry a picture on New York Post or
something they carry rabies yeah that
dog sold his likeness years ago for
stock photos
that looks so nice too such a good dog
that's not that's not a stray dog that's
a white person's dog in the Greenwich
Village yeah that's a white person in
Portland because the Portland sweatshirt
yeah custom-made that's a lab that dog
owns his own Starbucks
he seems friendly man yeah well this
List's some [__] they I knew it was
[__] when there that sloth [__]
sloth beer on there yeah no no
I can't believe you're saying this
you're talking about the bring up how
many people are killed by sloth bears
they're the most they kill more people
than any other bear by far
consider one of the most dangerous
animals in Asia only 20 000 remain in
the wild bears 12 people a year one a
month damn and you don't believe in the
[__] smiley face killers they kill
more than the sloth bear I don't know
dude 12 12 a year not a problem no you
get eaten ass first that's a shitty way
to all beers he does first I know
Grizzlies kill more people than that I
don't want to mess with a sloth dude 12
a year that's a lot [__] you dude look
at that thing I don't want to die by
dude that peanuts kill more people look
at that thing dude I don't want to die
that way whoa that's the worst bear of
all time lions and sloth bear I mean
tigers and sloth bears sloth bears get
eaten by tigers but they have some
battles they have some battles that's a
rough hold down and usually bears are
cute these things are ugly as [__] well
they have you can race attached to you
those things are stupid no you can raise
them
you're like it's a real problem bringing
up like 12 in the history of mankind no
no once a year one once a month there's
a lot
how did it die it was so Sarah he died
it's a heart attack sloth bear that's
the next question look at those stupid
bears oh they're cute look at the teeth
on that [__] dude that is a big animal
that's a dog that's that's bigger than
anything I'll tell you what I'm not
jacking off his feet look at how long
their tongues are
I think this is a different bear no
that's it that's a song yeah sun bears
you said you wanted to hear the weight
yeah what do they weigh
200 pounds 300 way so [__] time 300
it was stupid hey dude respect the sloth
bear bro I think you could take down a
sloth bear I'd give it a good go what
more than a Grizzly or like a black yeah
obviously but that's a sloth bear he's
not hearing a peep out of you kills 12
starving Indian people a year he's not
here enough people they have no strength
he's coming at you right there and
biting you dude I'm not worried about
that stuff you're not worried about out
of all the Bears yes 300 pound bear kill
you if you'd pick out of all the beers
that's the one you'd picked you know how
strong they bite
yeah I'm not worried about it
12 a year you you don't [__] with a
sloth another stupidness you're not
hearing a peep out of a sloth bear no
they hit those chops look at those
stupid chops down their face they don't
have a neck one we're gonna do against
it punch it [__] kick it running the
stupid nose it's not hearing a peep out
of your kick you've never you were never
a kicker even in the UFC does the sloth
bear have the weakest bite among Bears
correct it does that's a form small
teeth and standard jobs compared to
other various product Foods or insects
fruits and honeybees
um oh gross this guy goes even sun bears
have more impressive Jaws roast
roast I was so pissed off right now
she's pissing me out oh hey look
hey look there's no [__] about bears all
quiet in the [__] Corner over there
yeah I don't know sorry I'm sorry I'm
letting you guys talk about bears for 10
minutes on the podcast sorry quick bring
up the Dan DeVito video
you're being quiet not having any input
or whether you can find a bear or not
playing flip-flops we've really covered
a lot of ground yeah man how'd you get
into sacks huh third fourth grade I saw
somebody playing it and I was like I
want to play that yeah yeah you play it
well Lisa Simpson was in your
inspiration no but I mean I always
thought it was cool yeah I thought it
was cool jam out on yeah of course I
feel like that inspired a lot of kids
probably probably subconsciously yeah
yeah yeah how well do you play
I would say I'm an intermediate player
anybody so I can from zero to Kenny G oh
dude I'm very intermediate when I get
around when I get around
um professional well Kenny G plays the
uh what's it called the soprano but he
plays the sax he put what do you mean he
thought he played did he play the read
what is that thing the clarinet he's not
a gay man oh you think he's Kenny G's
got famous from playing the clarinet
yeah he plays a clarinet no that's a
saxophone he's playing that's a soprano
Saxon he's playing the long straight
saxophone that's a soprano sex he's
famous for that but he plays tenor he
plays he plays all so he plays all of it
yeah but he's known as American sex
funnies got it Kenny G I played a club
in uh Hawaii where he had just performed
there a few uh weeks before me and I was
like yeah yeah that'd be cool shuts the
place down so so I stand corrected uh
anybody
what instrument did you think what you
do for snakes Kenny G's doesn't play the
flute you think he got massive famous
from playing the flu yeah the clarinet
the clarinet the
clarinetics did you yeah wow that says a
lot about you man yeah I couldn't yeah
because I'm too uh too virile
um so you who you're you're you're gonna
say you're oh when I get around it's
just like okay
like if you like you guys you know you
box and MMA and stuff like that when you
spar with when you spar with somebody
who really knows what they're doing
you're like oh different level it's a
different level so like if I play like
my favorite sax player is this guy named
Leo P he uh is part of this group called
too many zoos it's like a Subway group
that started off like that like a bunch
of viral videos and stuff like that they
would pop off like playing in the Subway
and then they play in the streets in New
York and stuff like that he's done my
podcast he's done Jeremiah wonders and
scissor Bros he is very nice and he'll
like riff around with me but like I can
just feel like he has to lower his level
to play with me because he's so good he
looks awesome oh dude he is he's my
favorite sax player all the time he's
the man dude yeah he looks it hell yeah
yeah he plays a baritone that's a good
look right there that's
oh he's cool dude he this dude's got a
style
oh yeah look at that big purple sex
that's a badass sex yeah
well so so he uh he's gonna blow that
thing so he's in a couple different
groups like uh uh two sacks he's one of
his groups with uh Grace Kelly and then
like uh he's got a another uh like
there's there's like a sax community of
these people who are like All-Stars
Michael Wilbur's another amazing sax
player um he's just got crazy chops
crazy chops and they make super Unique
Sounds with sacks where you wouldn't
associate it with that where they can
play like dubstep on sax and then I
guess the goal of sex though if you're
if you play an instrument is to get in
like the Chicago Symphony and [__] right
I have a cousin who plays the violin and
he was he was like
you know how for UFC fights they have a
guy who weighs in in case somebody falls
out he's that guy like he flies there if
someone falls out he fills in right
because you can't have something he's
like a master of it but those guys it's
like being a punter in the NFL they
stick around forever so you gotta hope
somebody dies they're Flawless right
they're Flawless and they and every
conductor has a different interpretation
of of the piece you know so sometimes
you're playing you know to all different
kinds of ways like I said one conductor
will take a composition and it'll sound
totally different from another one but
it's all but you have to be on point you
can't have you can't have your third
violin be not good they can the thing
about conductors they can have a like a
a I don't know 25 people in an orchestra
and they can hear when somebody's off
they can be like hey you know uh you're
sharp you're flat yeah don't the
conductors have the longest lifespan too
because their arms are always above
their heart you know that no yeah the
longest lifespan of any job is that true
yeah because they're constantly like
this
supposedly this is good for you I guess
so because I can't see doing this
[__]
I don't think so Bubba but that sounds
like the longest lived males were
conducted that sounds like a manser's
fact now look shows the longest lived
males working down in the back too right
yeah yeah it's like I read it off a
Snapple cat back in 92.
there's the 38 longer than the general
population that's so cool the reason
it's simple conductor is
that that's such a random he's got a lot
of those randomly
yep wow conducting is good
cardiovascular exercise it is right
you're here dude we should play a thick
boy jeopardy with you
that's why Griffin's always like oh I'd
kill you in Jeopardy I'm like oh dude I
would blow your doors off wow my my
babysitter was Jeopardy
yeah it's weird I know that [__] that's
really interesting yeah it's because
their arms are 38 longer insane right
yeah hey B let's take a little break
before we get back chatting just about
being weird with Jeremiah Watkins Scuba
Steve in the house listen if you guys
are looking for the best products on the
planet especially the number one
nootropic on the freaking planet they've
sold over a million bottles of regular
Alpha Brain but that's just all they
offer they have Alpha Brain instant you
put in a little eight ounce of cold
water your boom and daddy Alpha Brain
Black Label which your boy uses I use
four pills and dude I'm I'm creating
programs apps what yeah dude it's the
Limitless oh dude Alpha Brain Focus shot
quick little shot Gets Ready Alpha Brain
pre-workout I want sleep though I need
sleep okay for sleep okay Digestive
Health sure dude daily support we got it
all they got essential nutrients yep and
the summer's coming it's a thick boy
summer so make sure you get your thick
supplements they got protein powders
they got creatine they got freaking uh
krill oil joint oil total human Health
they got it all for you they got Fitness
Gear they got kettlebells Primal Bells
on-demand workouts steel Club Macy's
home fitness programs they have yoga
mats on it sandbags they got it all go
to audit.com
f-a-t-k Temp South all the Alpha Brain
including Alpha Brain Black Label all
the kettlebells the freaking mood new
mood melatonin spray told gut health all
10 off audit.com
f-a-t-k temps off everything clone Alpha
Brain you're welcome let's get back to
the program scuba Steve's part of it's
also um there's a book called Beyond
border man now don't act like you know
now though right well part of what the
troops do well no so so conductors get
into Flow State
uh check please no no conductors
surgeons rock climbers painters they did
a study on the on the state they get
into the Flow State they get into uh
shiksen mihali
shiksen I got camera's name he's a he's
a Hungarian scientist wrote a book
called beyond boredom anxiety and he's
the first person to study flow he's the
first guy to coin this the thing Flow
State and he took all those jobs and
they get into a a hypnotic State and
that's good for your health too Total
Focus but yes anyways it's because they
put their arms above like I said right
well it's also their mindset yeah but
Flow State could be in any profession so
here you studied those professions but
there's basketball players getting flow
States there's five or skin flow States
there's comic skin flow States so you
just took that sample size it doesn't
tell us I bet you people who get into
Flow State a little bit longer maybe
because they love their jobs have you
ever felt like you're in Flow State
truly yes with stock wise stand up stand
up
yeah I had an experience it was in
Sacramento and I was like you know you
know when you're about to shoot your
special and everything is clicking and I
was I felt like I was playing the
audience as an instrument
like I felt like I was like able to
breathe life into that side because they
were losing a little energy then I would
take energy away from them there were
two they were laughing too hard then
I've had the middle so I was playing it
like I don't know just I I I wasn't
worrying about anything else other
people like energy
I was like a hornless Kenny G I was like
a saxless Kenny G a hairless Kennedy
because he has all this oh yeah he has
all the hair still oh yeah oh dude oh
dude yeah a real man I'd love to have my
hair yeah all right Jim what do you got
first
all right first one it just happened so
we talked about this on the shop show
Nate Diaz yeah he got into a couple of
Street scuffles and so he's actually he
has an arrest warrant out for him right
now yeah this is part of the problem
like this day and age with social media
like I I said play stupid games Win
stupid prizes prom is they can just sue
him you know but he really needs to like
Luke Thomas said it best he's like at
this stage of the game Nathan and he has
the money like he needs Professional
Security so they de-escalate this stuff
so he does like the money he'll save on
lawsuits and stuff can do wonders
correct so he should have security
because he's a hot head obviously right
so if you have security they're not
gonna let him get in these situations
yeah so his attorney saying that they're
doing a you know a self-defense claim
sure obviously he'll be fine though
because there's another angle in the
video that shows like everyone's
fighting around him like everyone's
chaotic and that guy who approached Nate
was a professional fighter and was going
towards and Nate was trying to like back
up and so I was like all right dude so I
looked up that guy you know they kept
saying he's a Logan Paul look-alike but
I thought they just said he just looked
like Logan Paul but I guess he looks
like him so much that Logan Paul did
videos with him right and then I looked
at his MMA record
this is old school he's zero six and oh
okay
okay but uh he just took the biggest
hell in his life well he's not a probe
right that's him he looks a lot like
Logan Paul right he looks like Logan
Paul if he did math that's a lot yeah
people are saying that he's meth Paul
that is Drugs That's math Paul
yeah that's math ball that's math Paul
that's really interesting
all right this next one I'm a little
late to the party on this but have you
guys seen this video no of this woman
complaining about a guy that approached
her so I'll just play it for you
she deleted the original videos this
someone else that uploaded sorry at 12
million I'm literally shaking right now
because I just had a man approach me in
a parking lot and it went fine and I'm
gonna tell you why I went fine and how
to address it because it was in a book I
read and this is how you're supposed to
address it but it scared me I'm
literally I'm literally shaking I can't
wait so this guy I'm a alone with my son
by myself a woman and a male approached
me in a parking lot he's excuse me
missing I don't know why in the hell he
was approaching me or what he was trying
to do and before he I mean he was
probably 30 feet from me when he said
excuse me ma'am and I turned around and
I literally yelled at him and I said do
not approach me and he like good for you
immediately started going in the other
direction I just kept saying it over and
over and over I said do not approach me
do not approach me and he of course like
got like
what's your problem and I and I looked
at him and he started he actually then
crossed a couple cars down from my car
and he didn't come anywhere near me he
crossed a couple cars not from my car
and was like what so he did nothing
he did nothing you do not approach women
in a parking lot I just kept saying do
not approach me you
yeah hell yeah
I bet she's great at barbecues should
ever approach a woman never ever never
shoot your shot in a parking lot ever
turn around and use the strongest voice
that you can just showed women's rights
they need to literally screw off
he just said excuse me right he's like
excuse me oh my God
this is this fourth wave hysterical
feminism that is just like uh this is
this is good for the movement though
because then people see how crazy it is
the reason she took the video down she
thought it was gonna go a different way
than people like hey dumb [__]
everybody's even the same thing too
that's what if you dropped your purse
get away from me yeah dude no I know you
do not look at me he's so dumb she's
like why he was coming up to me I have
no [__] clue okay well you're dumb I
know shaking she's also she's just this
is good but it's good that they out
themselves it's like a hater a troll
who's hiding and is doing nasty [__]
once they finally out themselves and you
know what you're dealing with that this
is good for the movement this is what
people are like oh this is what people
have to this what single white males
have to deal with like this Insanity
she's an awful person so you know when I
yell him he he backed up he was about
three cars
this is her explaining why she deleted
the video sucks
you suck
Let me refresh this oh my parking lot
video down for a couple reasons the
first one is I keep getting
along
the top ones the top one's a little
aggressive they're both the glitches
how hysterical she is she her body's all
tight she's touching dude this is like a
Kate McKinnon character I don't know
yeah she has a very strange it looks
like her body is very very tiny in our
heads it's just that effect also yeah I
think the camera's probably but she's
such a mess she's like she's just she's
probably scared because she's generally
afraid of course because she's never
gone viral and she went viral for the
wrong reasons the hate like she doesn't
realize what hate well she sucks as a
person she doesn't deserve that but you
should have your [__] punched so you
know that's so well of course she that's
the one she pulls yeah yeah yeah that's
that's you're gonna get
he said excuse me ma'am too like I know
excuse me ma'am excuse me I want to see
his video
dude she dropped her keys I would love
it yeah his his version of the story
nice guys like she had a kid I thought
you need help you do as a woman like
there is that thing where there are a
lot of [__] creeps out of course but
that was it but here's the thing the
majority are correct quit with that
narrative correct the majority that
she's a pretty girl you probably saw her
was like Hey excuse me maybe he's gonna
ask her out to dinner oh is that a bad
thing that's how people meet people
unless you're on the internet I think
though I think what happens is like
we're talking about like you can when
you read enough news and you read enough
about how people get abducted and killed
and raped and all you can [__] twist
yourself into it into a state of
Hysteria friends you're walking around
like that all the time
and you got your kid and you just your
use you're you're overly active you're
always ready always ready
so they also called her out for doing
the video in the parking lot where it
happened you know I mean if you're
freaked out wouldn't you just leave go
home and then yeah if you actually
thought he was a a harm to you and your
child are you gonna get on YouTube or
where the [__] Snapchat dude how great
would it be if she was right and then
the video like fists come flying through
have her dragged out of the garden or
the guy gets on the uh you know doesn't
give away himself he's like I'm actually
the smiley face killer so she did the
right thing yeah yeah just totally
retains herself how much is serial
killer so yeah you had a good she
actually she was uh she she spotted off
she was spot on I was about to Slit her
throat and make her child watch uh so in
her defense I wanted to be a dad uh in
her defense I wanted to push her shitty
come take
face right now right now can't reveal my
true identity
the conscientious serial killer and
George Lucian I was a little out of hand
this is a video I found of Pete Davidson
he was everyone was coming up to him
after I think the Lakers game and he
lost Knicks a little bit next game this
must be exactly and then some guy grabs
them right yeah
it's like an older Dude too
right there right what what he put his
arm around him like that I'm sure
everyone's bumping into him and stuff
and then the guy goes to grab him he's
probably just had enough he's like get
the [__] out of here you shouldn't touch
people anyway yeah but would you do that
to somebody like would you do that to
just a random stranger because like he's
a stranger to you yeah you see him on TV
or YouTube or whatever your favorite
show or movie but you don't know him so
it's weird for him I've seen that happen
to some pretty famous people and they
snap like that the [__] are you doing
yeah I'm not your prop you know
I mean that's what happened with the
Mike Tyson thing on the flight that
happened a long time ago but yeah like
exactly what are you gonna do like you
don't know him yeah you don't know I
don't know with Rogan and we're sitting
down we're eating after a show and we're
eating um some restaurant and it's
always like it was a group of like drunk
dudes in their late 20s and because
they're Oprah yep and they're a little
oh this was before Rogan became giant
but he was still selling 3500 it was
like Dr Phil back then yeah correct now
he's Oprah correct great that's actually
a great Dr Phil was always kind of like
you're like oh he knows Oprah yes we had
Dr Phil on scissor Bros recently really
yeah what big dude right yeah good guy
here yeah so he he basically comes in we
clock him and the guy the one guy's
drunk and he goes oh [__] hey hey hey
you you and and and Joe's sitting down
and the guy starts getting all familiar
and Joe goes yep how you doing how you
doing and the guy sits down right next
to Joe like almost on him like the Cena
a bad santa
yeah man like that and Joe goes Joe goes
okay I've had enough that's good and
just takes him and pushes him like this
you know how his hands he's got a giant
troll hands yeah and he just takes his
hand and just goes okay and he just goes
yeah and just throw it and the guy just
gets like he basically lifts him up and
pushes him out of the [__] man he's a
guy like broken just pushed me yeah
he didn't know his name was Joe Rogan he
just knew he hates you so he just yeah
that's even worse this [__] [__] out
of the thing and it was so obvious that
there was that was the only warning you
were gonna get that was the only warning
the decided yeah if you decide it was
going to be more it was going to be
probably something Jujitsu related but
yeah
[__] how about you and I have seen
him shut things off when guys get way
too familiar yeah he'll go uh you're
good you got your picture you're good oh
my God I wish that's more like have
either of you had to ever use MMA in a
public situation or Republican
we were surrounded by King Cobra so if
you fell out of the way you'd get bitten
so yeah sloth bears yeah yeah it wasn't
a sport it was fine yes okay that wasn't
smart yeah uh no never say inside never
yeah they don't [__] with him like they
don't I wouldn't think so well he's too
big you know like when we would take
pictures and stuff if I'm alone they
grab me some guy's a big grab me the
mean greets they grabbed me but yeah not
so much anymore I don't get too bad
yeah you know any issues didn't you have
a lady jump on stage didn't I see that
on uh social media dude I because I
improvise and riff with the crowd a lot
like in my headlining sets like I'll go
in and out of material my favorite sets
are like I'll go in and out of material
where people will come up to me after
show they're like I don't know what was
material that's like my favorite it kind
of shows
um and in my special that's kind of what
I do is I go in and out of material it's
mainly material but I'll riff with the
crown stuff like that but
I have had so many I feel like way more
than the average comic of weird
interactions of people thinking it's
okay to do stuff because I'm so losing
it's a loosey-goosey kind of yeah I roll
with it where people think that they can
sometimes go like and do weird stuff or
like I've had multiple people walk on
stage where I have to deal with it and
stuff like that where like then the
security will have to grab them and it's
very bizarre like the people like are
like oh yeah I'm friends with this guy
now like anything goes it's a party yeah
yeah it's weird yeah
I never had that no not really never
anybody on stage
yeah I feel like you do get a lot man
I've had the vibe you give I don't well
I think it's loose and then also if if
there's something that's going on like
where if if they think that they can get
the best of me because I look a certain
way they're like ah this guy he's just
gonna take it I'm like no no I'm not
gonna just sit here when uh Will Smith
rushed the stage and then Chappelle had
the same thing happen where like I got
tackled and then they beat the [__] out
of them I mean our CA was like all the
clubs are worried that it's gonna be a
huge uproar and people start rushing the
stage I think we're going to up security
I'm like uh
I think I'm all right I don't think
maybe no let him try maybe maybe call
another comic I think I should be all
right yeah but what would you do if
somebody like so okay a couple times in
this [__] face if somebody started
walking towards you if I thought
somebody was coming on I'm telling you
who I'm telling you right now if
somebody if somebody decided to come on
stage and I thought they were they were
going to be aggressive yeah I mean I
even at The Comedy Store I you know if I
feel like you're being aggressive toward
me in the in the crowd depending on my
mood it's you know
if you come on stage to me I consider
that a threat and I'm going to I'm going
to punch you and ask questions later and
I'm gonna keep punching I'm sure you've
seen the classic uh like it's from like
the 80s the guy the guitar comic who who
the guy comes at him on stage breaks the
guitar and he's like he awesome he's
coming right at me it's like it's way
too much
you know you know Tino he's friends with
Tripoli he's a black Belgian Jiu Jitsu
great guy he rescues dogs he's just a
really good guys of comic he's such a
sweetheart
um this in there's a video of it in
Vegas the guy just [__] starts like
yelling at him from the thing and then
starts threatening and and Tina's like
you know and then he starts walking
towards him and Tina's like look I'm
stop I'm telling you stop I don't want
to fight you I don't want to yeah but
Tina's like you know he knows how to
fight and the guy comes right in there
and you know just goes he's just [__]
front Sparta kicks him right in this
hole
like that and you see they have to help
him oh it's a disaster but it was like
the [__] well there's that one comment
used the black comic and he was he was
roasting some dude in his girl and the
guy was like you say my girl's name one
more time I'll come up there and you say
I'm telling you say what you want man
and he's like having fun with it and he
keeps roasting his girl and the guy goes
up there in security before he got
knocks him out and then the guy just
roasts the [__] I told y'all do not come
up here Security's giant I got in San
Antonio a guy in the audience he didn't
like the interaction that I was having
with him uh because his girl was like
passing out and I was like yo is she
good like all this stuff and he
threatened to stab me from the crowd
that's a problem yeah yeah that's a
problem I remember when uh Rusty Dooley
uh-huh we're at the comedy store in La
Jolla and this woman is drunk and she's
talking and he goes I'm not doing
another I'm not saying another word
until you get the [__] out of here and
was he was he's in costume while he's
having to do this thing killing it yeah
and she goes you're joking is I'm a
professional comedian and I'm definitely
not joking get out of here
so she gets up and she says my husband's
a Navy SEAL he'll kick your [__] ass
and her husband wasn't just a Navy SEAL
he was like a 40 Year Old Navy SEAL you
know those guys have been Navy Seals for
20 years where they're probably like
steel Team Six whatever this is the
first time I'd ever seen like he
literally was just he built like Brennan
like shorter but built like Brennan just
like thick as [__] in a mock turtleneck
like that like and a white shirt just a
back on him and we you know as a guy you
see right away you're like oh that's guy
with like one of these noses she's like
oh God you know I don't know what the
[__] is going on shaved head I don't
want any part of this guy obviously very
familiar with violence sure and if you
know me I talk a big game I'm like I'm
around comics guys think I'm MMA guy so
uh so wait so you're not an MMA guy well
I'm an underground oh okay but I don't
use first rule of Fight Club yeah thank
you no I can't swore
shoes
um I not well so I like I I like to
fight with my with my feet on sheathed
right I don't yeah
in a house yeah I don't keep them
confined yeah we should fight soon what
I think we should fight soon
laughs
okay I'm so busy wait so did the Navy
SEAL yeah so what happened with the Navy
SEAL oh so you've been drafting this 40
year old neighbors it goes like this
Rusty ghost Rusty goes uh yeah well your
husband should probably give you a
[__] slap
because you talk too much
and the guy goes like this I know around
he he's walking out and he just goes
like this he just turns and starts
walking towards the stage
and Rusty to his credit goes let's go
man let's go let's go no yeah he's doing
this thing you know you know Rusty's not
taking [__] but Rusty's built like me
Rusty's not you know an MMA fighter and
he's not an MMA fighter he's not an MMA
fighter so uh the the security who's not
really security at the Communist tour
guys they're door guys who are kind of
comics they kind of like try to figure
out a way to Usher him in and I I what I
what scared me was now I'm there in case
something pops off I'm looking at this
guy's back he's got that triangle back
big dude and and uh and he goes like
this he goes uh you do you think I was
being offensive you want me to get
offensive with you I'll get offensive
with you he's saying that to our manager
the manager and what scared me was that
the two people he was with was a couple
and one guy was a big dude they were so
terrified of they were they were they
were so afraid of what he was supposed
to have a flashlight
I never they were like it's okay the big
guy was going hey John it's okay man
John John please please John so they
were begging him and I was like we don't
need another box yeah right something's
amiss here and uh thank God the cops the
cops [__] walk in oh nothing happened
nothing happened the cops walk in and he
leaves but I remember I was like if
something pops up here I don't think I'm
gonna jump in you're all [__] we're
all fine no yeah we're all [__] he's
gonna do some [__] did you jump him he
was going to bite you and pull your eye
out or some [__] what a schedule here's
a quick one this Chinese couple did an
Airbnb and somewhere in South Korea and
then they try to cancel it I think last
minute and then they're like no you
still have to pay for it because it's
too last minute so they turned on all
the different utilities the water the
gas the electricity all that stuff and
then got to another property but they
came back like often to make sure
everything's still turned on to waste
all their yeah but apparently it came
out to about 1 500 in utilities I
thought it'd be way more for 25 days
yeah did I tell you my my wife has an
Airbnb and it was during covid and a
Chinese family from China
was kind of stuck and they wanted to
rent it for a month
and my wife was like okay you know I
remember it was like and she's like yeah
of course my husband my husband's Asian
of course
so he can he can interpret yeah and uh
I never tell you she was a little
hesitant because they're Chinese no it
wasn't that she just was having trouble
communicating with the woman but the way
she told the story she was like kind of
broken English she was like I feel bad
for the family and stuff like this seems
like a scam
well she had um a huge Koi pond with
beautiful Koi like outside of the you
know and uh they all disappeared
they all disappeared Green Barbecue what
do you mean they ate all her koi Korean
barbecue all the koi was good yeah
they're hungry and then and then what's
on you Daddy they thought that that was
the sampler platter that was outside and
she like she had four sheep they killed
him they had three Lambs they ate them
they fish ate them like all her koi fish
that were like big like you like fish
like they [__] at them for they came
with the house dude I'm not Asian I'm
not gonna eat a pun but the dude play
stupid games with stupid prize what it
is you're gonna stock up no I get a nice
Pond full of fresh fish for the series
even better and then you got the grill
sizzling form right you walked them into
it right walk them into it gets better
we get there and the ground the flooring
had been cut out like parts of the floor
the wood floor had been cut out like in
blocks really neat blocks and they put
beads in there it was like it almost
looked like it would be a cool that's
what I mean it looked like a cool design
like if you had had then you put like if
you put like
um laminate over it or something I could
have got it so look at that knife it
looked kind of nice but it just wanted
to Sparkle they didn't put any plastic
they didn't put anything over it it was
just they cut out the beads would like
fall when you walk yeah they put the
beads in there like all over the house
well you're gonna have to charge then we
had to take all the rugs out and switch
out the couch because they were cooking
with grease and the the the the film on
the kitchen the grease was like that
thick it was the most bizarre [__] ever
try to get in touch with them of course
they went back to China never got in
touch wow did they pay though they
certainly did not this never got any
money from them I don't know like made
up like Asian hate propaganda story
where it's like listen the Chinese
people came in they ate all our fish
they threw their grease all over the
goddamn walk it's a weird family and
everyone
Samurai geese all over the place
their bats were hanging in the Attic
yeah they didn't let the cleaning people
in there
I'm not I'm not participating in This
Racist they didn't let the cleaning lady
in there turn the Airbnb a goddamn wet
Market
[Applause]
camera but they wouldn't they kept
saying we don't need somebody to come
and clean we we're cleaning for you well
that should have been the red flag
there's so many red flags in all this
for your wife yeah yeah I mean Jay have
an Airbnb Scott how long did they say
well Chris her friend who cleans her
house Christine they stayed for three
years yeah no they were there for I
think they were there a month two months
but but they're paying the pop-up shop
but the problem was when they came back
all your cool you're gone she was like
he killed my boy there are no coin in
the pond they ate all the coins if your
wife is like nah it's gonna be fine she
turns on the ring camera and you just
see that Chinese family grabbing the hit
him over the head with a ham and she's
like oh my God just ripping
ate them all
they paid but the the deposit would not
there has to be something where Airbnb
can track them down they were in China
it was so expensive like they did real
damage oh dude cut up the phone we had
we had to get rid of the rugs we had to
put the new flooring in parts of ramen
noodles and then get a professional
cleaner that didn't work in the kitchen
because of the grease because the grease
got on the couch and everywhere so it
became
yeah right
the fan without the fan on yeah I had a
roommate who used to cook like that that
it would get grease all over the stove
and stuff he just like oh it's
impossible it's pretty disgusting it's
disgusting yeah Greece is not a yeah
yeah the Airbnb now because there's so
many horror stories like that now
because you know we do airbnbs when
we're on the road people will be like
well no you're under whatever 50 and
you're gonna throw parties and you're
like no it's just me and my brother yeah
the headline comic like comic there's
gonna be parties at that you get
reviewed now so you get reviewed but you
have to offer good reviews because if
you the way it works it's such a [__]
up system if you leave them a bad review
and it's completely honestly like
everyone was nice the the house is neck
and we've had this happen the house is
next to a train station sitting here
trains all through the night don't stay
here if you have kids you leave a bad
review then they leave you a battery
horrible customers you have to place
dirty so then you can't rent places
right so you're scared to leave a battle
review that's the problem
that's a real that's actually a real
flaw in the system it's horrible flaws
because you can't see it like in
Kentucky we literally gorgeous house is
but the backyard was a straight up train
track every two hours from 10 P.M to 7
A.M
whole house shaking huge problem so I
told Jay I'm like hey just let anybody
know it's but literally a train you
called me is behind he sent me you sent
me I sent a video it's four in the
morning
like that I'm like I got no sleep right
I told Jim like just leave a review so
people know he's like we can't if we do
they're gonna dock this then we can't
[__] another oh that's crazy yeah it's
nuts fall in the system yeah it could be
worse though could have Asian family
kill all your fish and create a [__]
walk correct what else you got Jen walk
yeah you don't want to walk this man by
the way Ramen Ramen is like a Japanese
Just for future reference oh no I was
talking the smell oh okay yeah yeah all
right yeah I let that one slide yeah me
too
come on yeah and also there the whole
thing that they want they went to airbn
Airbnb to you know handle it but they're
like no that's your that was your
customer for your Airbnb so you got to
take care of it yeah that's what happens
Airbnb couldn't help us with that yeah
all right this is a little mysterious
like I think a few weeks ago or a week
ago Jamie Foxx's daughter said that her
dad's like recovering the hospital some
complicated illness right he was like in
Maine yeah he was filming and then I
guess even Cameron Diaz who's not done a
movie in a long time she ended up doing
the movie with James yeah so it was kind
of a cool story but then
she said he was in the hospital but
there's no one's saying like what it is
or whatever but all these different I
think I know what it is they keep it
tight to the chest so a lot of people
you know a bunch of celebrities coming
out seeing wishing support and they're
saying he's better now and all that
stuff but he's still in the hospital the
only thing I heard beforehand was his
big dick
that too but he I guess he's like
filming and then kind of did a little
bit of a tirade and fired four different
people yeah he like lit up the cat like
some of the staff right yeah yeah and
they're on professional suddenly this
thing happened
he's got sick from being too talented no
I think I think he is the most talented
they get a stroke really you think so
there's a blood clot and he's just
making it up and that's why it's so
Under Wraps because they're worried
about like any photos or anything well a
blood clot you know is uh so a stroke is
a blood clot like that that stops it can
be anywhere in your body but but um it's
in the brain that's the aneurysm right
it's a it's it's uh it's the problem
with the stroke is it'll shut off oxygen
into parts of your brain now can crows
uh
oh everybody loves Jamie Foxx but I
wonder I wonder why the Cuban's so
terrible because like Jeremy Renner shot
a [__] special on his injury well
because things like shut up things like
uh things like if you have if you have a
stroke or you have something like that I
hope it's not a stroke I I shouldn't be
talking this way but
I feel like you made up a stroke and now
you're backtracking no but um but if it
is that then
I think you don't want people knowing
that why
because it changes my guess you have to
give some excuse me like why are you in
the hospital for two months my guess is
it's a lot more serious than
you know Bill that people know by the
way when you're in the hospital for two
months we don't have to serious it's not
serious right like it's really serious
it's like Bernie Mac like when he passed
away like oh we had no clue or like that
Chad Boswick or whatever from Black
Panther and like everyone's making fun
of them I know you look sick yeah the
reason the reason you don't say that is
because you can't get bonded so you you
when you do a big movie The Promo no you
can't get bonded you can't get insured
so when you have a sickness like yeah
you cannot you literally can't work
because because the studios can't
insurance does your own health insurance
would cover it right no no the studio
the film has to get Bond the film has to
have insurance so if so think about it
you have probably a thousand people who
get a job the minute you say yes to a
movie at least a thousand people this is
the Tom Cruise thing too yeah
um and you're talking about a machine
that gets in motion once it gets in
motion you're talking about guarantees
of a hundred million dollars yes
guarantees yeah
you cannot have your star
um get sick because what happens is it
all goes away and everybody loses
everybody loses their money it's
financiers yeah it's the money people
yeah and money people [__] what they do
is they go what's going on with them
how is he sick well they're not gonna
make the bed that'd be like making a bet
on you know on jokic if you found out he
was really sick yeah you're just like
I'm getting into that no so Jonathan
Majors who got in trouble with this
domestic stuff
um Marvel pulled out and and yeah such a
big problem because Marvel had was
building everything on that but isn't it
interesting that Marvel pulled out and
then with the kid from flash being oh no
they're letting it ride because the kid
from flash has all this crazy [__] uh no
I don't know
Ezra Miller Ezra Miller he has all this
crazy like clearly mentally ill doing
all this crazy [__] but because he's the
Flash and they've put Millions hundreds
of million dollars in vets and he's the
flash they're still riding with him
Jonathan Majors he was just getting
started so they have the money in Beth
him so they kicked him the curve well
that's also there's also other things
coming out with the majors yeah
you breaking news yeah
dude I know I hope I'm wrong about it
hold on security footage rolling around
a village Jonathan is accuser at Club
Dance on the night of the incident yeah
so apparently she said she was you know
abused that night but then went out to a
club and you can see footage of her and
then they have like an upper spirits
upper spare time
but but this is significance
for his case text saying like you know I
guess when and when anyone ever says
something about abuse someone has to get
arrested which we talked about before
right yeah man or woman so she
apologized and apparently through the
text it's kind of pretty long but this
is from March 30th I think
uh please let me know you're okay when
you get this they assured me they won't
be charged they said they had arrest you
as protocol when they saw the injuries
on me and they knew we had a fight so
they did I'm sorry you're in this
position we'll make sure nothing happens
about this I told him it was my fault
for trying to grab your phone I only
just got out of the hospital just call
me when you're out
they just call again check out me I re
rear ready how this was not attacked
they do not have my Bliss on any charges
being placed
I read the paper they gave me about
strangulation and said Point Blank that
did not occur and should be removed
immediately the judge is definitely
going to be told this she insured this
to me I know you have the best team and
there's nothing to worry about I just
want you to know that I'm doing all I
can on my end I also said to tell the
judge to know that the origin of the
call was to do with me collapsing and
passing out and your worry is my partner
due to our complications communication
prior out of care she promised all this
will be relayed that's significant so
this is significant to me Majors lawyer
provided these texts so we don't know if
it's 100 sure but most likely well that
is that's that's her so so to me that's
and so the reason why she grabbed this
whole career when this was clearly some
way more complicated than we know so she
grabbed this phone because he was
apparently texting with another girl
maybe she got pissed off and then
whatever yeah saying that she was
assaulted is yes she said I love you she
leaves him this thing and she and she's
out dancing that night okay yeah but B
weren't you saying uh previous this
you're seeing a different tune saying
there's no stuff coming out on them so
so that's what [__] him so the reason I
think that the he got dropped so quickly
was because they know what was but but
see here's the other thing there are
people talking to the D.A saying he
abused me too you got to understand you
gotta understand also there's money
here for a lot of people it's not yes so
what happens is they go this
motherfucker's got money now so what you
do is you go and you say so you get the
lawyers talking and I've always talk to
other lawyers
to get this out of here and then but if
they were smart they would have waited
until he did his next Marvel movie and
got all more well they're not smart and
people yeah they're bad people bad
people well you jump on it when there's
you know a pile on but so I think he
might be able to weather this now that
happened I hope he does I love that
actor I I don't know what his situation
is great in Apollo Creed I don't I don't
know I don't know enough about what's
going on I don't know but that's the
internet in general like they jumped a
conclusion right away like confirmation
bias like oh yeah he's a bad guy it's
like I think there might be more let's
be very clear if somebody accuses you of
something I have some experience when
somebody accuses you of something they
get a story in your life about that yeah
your life is done so you know I I'm
obviously I'm obviously have
confirmation bias here yeah I'm a little
biased but it's great that these things
are coming up you know because I just
saw you here as the accuser but you
don't see all the proof If you have a
pendulum swing the other way where it's
like yeah and after so many good guys
without any evidence
at least people I'm around go you hear
about Jonathan major I'm like yeah do we
know anything like no let's see what
happens like at least they're not like
yeah get them out of there yeah like
let's see what happens before it was
that way just get him out before it was
like no matter what get them out if you
don't if you have a system like that
you're next everybody's next yeah just
depends on who's in power and who likes
you and who doesn't so but you're right
it's swinging the other way you're too
quiet on this this is my favorite NPR
show I'm listening to yeah
all right let's move on move on let's
move on all right so I don't know much
about football obviously but Aaron
Rodgers I guess he got traded to the
Jets so it finally happened so it's
massive so everyone was worried that
because the remember the trade talks of
him leaving Green Bay said he was out of
Green Bay This months ago months ago and
then finally and we was gonna happen
right around the draft because the team
need to make the deal happen because the
draft is Thursday I've never missed a
draft I watch all the [__] rounds so
now that he's at the Jets the Jets the
one thing they just didn't have they got
a good great defense and good uh
position players but they don't have a
really good quarterback not everyone
Rogers they're about to be [__] good
really good I'm an Aaron Rodgers fan I'm
a Kansas City guy so we've been having
some good years yeah you guys are
crashing up yeah
yeah it's crazy it's crazy I think he's
the best of all time even this I don't
think it's too early to call it now like
you look at what it's done now the best
we've ever seen I mean it's hard to he's
unbelievable
so fun to watch because like as a Chiefs
fan growing up like so much heartbreak
like where we get so close to playoffs
or we'd be like booted yeah Joe Montana
Steve deberg
that's about it I mean
look at Alex I used to work I used to
work around obviously around Kansas City
and I used to work at this Italian
restaurant where Jared Allen would come
in hell yeah and dude he would order so
much food it's crazy to see what NFL
guys like because they burn so many
calories like an All-Pro defensive end
yeah he was I mean he was so fun yeah so
huge yeah Beast
yeah that's big for the Jets massive
um
do you want two more ones like us
kind of a sad one the other one's just
whatever give us two then let's
bring up the sad one first we'll do that
so we can end on a good note yeah you
can always just end on the Danny veto oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right so
remember how that guy Bob Lee the one of
the creators of cash shop he was just
murdered in San Francisco and then they
thought it was just some random guy no
no yeah so they found out later on it's
another tech startup guy and a girl he
was like hooking up so his sister yeah
so apparently the guy that killed Bob he
was in the same it's just so weird
because Bobby has a joke about somebody
getting stabbed so this is like such a
way it's probably yeah yeah when I
whenever yeah
[Music]
but anyway so Bob Lee was in the same
circles as that that guy
what's Nemo or something like that and
that guy nema's sister was apparently
people were saying their friends like
you know uh we call it they have their
same kind of friends together they're
saying that there's potential that they
were romantic yeah she had a husband at
the time as well damn and then she
apparently yeah she apparently did a lot
of drugs with him so the brother got
pissed off found out later on
actually he called the Bob guy Bob guy
said hey was my sister doing drugs today
or anything like that he was like no
everything was cool ended up at her
apartment in the elevator then somehow
went to his car drove to a dark location
and then uh stabbed him sometimes then
he died so this guy from another country
wasn't he Iran I think
it's such a long story point there Brian
no that's just what are you going
killing [__] there's a lot of like you
know there's a lot of it's just
different they just don't they don't
play that kind of [__] so that's the guy
that's accused
yeah it's such a bummer man
and that's the girl that he was
apparently
that's a disaster uh whole thing's a
disaster yeah they did find out who did
it so it's not just some random dude
yeah no yeah this guy was in tech and
it's about some guy it's like a big
brother that's just overly protective
and yeah do you think you're gonna get
away with it in this day and age in San
Francisco with all those cameras like do
you think you're gonna have the guy in
your car he didn't care the chance of
him being back on the streets next week
in San France pretty good yeah if you're
gonna kill anybody kill the San Fran
you're right I'm a serial killer I'm
like hey fellas if I'm the smiley face
Killers I'm like let's get Sam from here
worst case we get a slap on them Austin
has a serial killer 100.
same group
Brian begs the differ yeah
I go to bars with water wings on yes I
do yes I do floaties on I always have my
phone when we're in Austin we go to bars
with floaties on just in case yes
bar yeah
yeah
as in
gay they call me Scuba Steve around us
the Scuba Steve this is
Iran oh you guys want to come down to
the river motorboat Morty over here yeah
dude
yeah yeah hey boys there's a barbecue
down on the [__] banks of the Austin
River we're opening our own club the
fathership
Daddy's Only Daddy
oh and I can go deep oh God you got it
broken you gotta have it I can hold my
breath membership oh like I got I like
cakes on my man oh it looks like we're
gonna need to please allow for this dick
if you can swim don't apply if you can
swim you ain't coming into the father
[__]
[Music]
I'll help you I'll be a rat yeah I'll be
your lifeline
hey wait man bro I am hey man how come
you stopped on the roof bro [__] bro
come on man we need you to hey we need
to do the deep end not in the shallowing
yeah [__] come on I like to go deep but
he got two days oh somebody's worried
that it's a real thing that's happening
oh no somebody's getting feelings if
it's me to Cross their legs for their
boner they're sticking out of their
jeans okay Brendan somebody needs a dick
at you no yeah no no no no no no no no
no
hey get his [__] head in the world
I'm still Scuba Steve but uh
and let's get to work he's like I'm fine
with the gay Behavior but just in doses
all right Justin doses what was the last
one chin all right it's not really a
happy one but it was an interesting one
I'll just show you real quick so another
guy died
this right here apparently this is
supposedly a trend of AI voices scamming
people like saying your sons in a
whatever in Peril you just you got to
send me some money but when I watch this
video it seems a little weird I'll play
it for you does it sound like a robot
oh no they're not even showing the road
really hard yeah well some sort of
influencer
I've been crying for the past last two
hours
because I thought my little brother was
dead it sounds like she needs Scuba
Steve
tricked my grandpa into thinking my
little brother got in a wreck and died
what The Fray he finished my brother's
voice and said I'm about to get a wreck
and then the phone went off and so my
grandpa called me and told me this and
I'm immediately thought my brother was
dead I started driving time to find his
location he wasn't picking up she's a
shoulder to cry now that it was a
scammer I'd like to kill the scammers
I'd like to kill the scam oh man it
sounds like a dem's own distress I like
how Brennan cuts off the other riff but
then he's like yeah it is sad girl he's
crying oh you need some thick shoulders
some thick boys shoulders
off yeah she didn't know their Scuba
Steve who's gay and then there's scuba
Stephen who's straight she needs scubas
you're a Pioneer you're non-binary when
it comes to sexuality oh yeah
yeah and and uh I'm so sorry I would
like to kill that scam wait wait let her
continue and just you'll see something
hopefully she plays the scanner
killed someone and he needed better
money
did somebody call the brother though
money he acted like my little brother
almost died if you guys ever get called
and
someone asking for money that you know
they're using a freaking AI machine so
basically she's saying that she thought
he was dead but then he's tried to
scammer out of money afterwards like it
doesn't doesn't make any sense you know
what I'm saying it was a guy like he's
gonna die
this is definitely have you venmo so
check this one I'm gonna figure this out
just send me 50 Grand to get the under
the case here okay there you go yeah it
doesn't mean yeah listen to this one
that you need to be aware of and it's
absolutely terrifying if you have ever
uploaded any videos to the internet a
Tick Tock YouTube video any video to the
internet you and your family could be
hit by this so keep watching this
morning my grandparents received the
call for me claiming that I was in a bad
car accident that I needed them to send
me money I did not even own a car I've
not driven the car in the last six
months jokes on them
mortgage
because they thought it was me pause it
pause it real quick hold on let me get
straight I'd be pissed if my dad got
that call sent the money before calling
yeah hey just call Brandy okay yeah I'm
fine what happened oh I just got a call
no I'm using my voice
yeah
call me dude because it's not gonna be
for myself if it's a random number
you're not gonna call mine if you call
me that guy if you call me if I have
your voice and you're like I really need
money I'd be like and Brian it's a plus
four four number well you're stupid and
old right so you would fall for it yeah
I would hold my family
why are you calling me from London I got
caught I came out here I Can't Tell You
Why Ryan's like wait where do you have a
Saudi Arabia numbers [__] now I got to
give you money weird right yeah but you
know Ryan Brian is Brendan I need some
money I need some money bro
Steve I don't know if this sounds it's a
scuba steve I need you to suck off six
men or they're gonna kill me you sound
like filmed it put on internet okay okay
I do believe you and trust you and then
after you send me like ah it's me dude
you suck those guys off to save my life
for fun
ER
um I I have skeptical hippos on this so
just I think it's happened to the stupid
old people no I think people can
definitely use it to trick people
especially older people
he said his grandparents were about to
take a second you know mortgage on and
then he goes luckily my dad was there
and he called me but I'm like why would
they how does this should call whatever
the kid's name is yeah let's call him
before we call the bank and it takes
forever to get a second doesn't this guy
look like he does uh I.T from Migos
he looks like the guy that's on computer
like let me figure it out yeah
yeah I found it
keep going I mean that's pretty much it
all right but I mean it's like you can
definitely scam people but these stories
just didn't sound that legit to me he's
all they said I got a car I don't have a
car yeah in your face and this girl
she's like a she has like a bunch of
followers too so I don't know if that
she has like 320k followers well she's
gorgeous she's definitely gorgeous her
boyfriend's very her boyfriend's a Navy
SEAL yeah it's a good ah let me just
assume everybody's Navy Seals here looks
like motorboat Morty is on the bottom
right now I don't know what that video
was
come on
yeah they didn't have babies right now
yeah right now for some reason I just
feel like when you have this many
followers you wouldn't [__] about
that but I don't know I don't think
she's [__] I think it happened I
think her Grandma and Grandpa are stupid
and no I don't think they're all like
mine would fall for it if they were
still alive no but she was crying saying
like she thought her brother was dead
and then the guy wanted money afterwards
to get out of jail or something but I
believe that that probably happened to
her and I think that there are people
like that so yeah wow she's the biggest
cup of tea in it
that is green tea I think she has it's a
handle on the other side it looks like
there's a giant cup she's impossibly
pretty
she's very cute yeah
deep down
hey man you were gay five minutes ago
well that's why yes sir that's why yes
what is it raft Iran okay
Jeremiah daddy is the name of the
special yes can't wait to see it it's on
YouTube right now yep I'm watching on
YouTube right now get you some full
special yep yeah on YouTube Jeremiah
Watkins Daddy what are you gonna be dude
uh coming up in Vegas in Kansas City but
I'm about to take a little bit of time
off the road just because
um the baby's coming in June so oh more
daddy power yeah love you brother good
to see you man yeah thank you sir
podcast Brandon thanks scuba D or
whatever your name is
wrapped you Ron go see rafty Ron in uh
comedy comedy zone I'll be there March
5th and 6th no no May anymore
damn it scuba May 5th and 6th and then
it's Stress Factory on their uh May 12
13 and then Helium Comedy Club I'm there
the 26th 27th and 28th
uh most of May I'll be doing spots
around La and then I picked back up in
June Comedy Store La Jolla that's Friday
Saturday Sunday June 2nd through the 4th
and I'm jumping all over to the pond
there I'm in uh it's a Europe uh UK tour
uh this is one night in every city it's
a theater run so we got Belfast Glasgow
Manchester London Cardiff Dublin that's
June 15th through the 25th I'm gonna
have a very special guest with me as
well so get your tickets at thickboy.com
Jeremiah go watch your special daddy
available right now on YouTube love you
guys